hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead do you guys
believe that aliens are real and one day
they'll come to invade Earth
a government facility in New Mexico
identifies an extraterrestrial signal
that comes from an object near the moon
at space command in the Pentagon the
secretary of defense is contacted about
this phenomenon the object is
approximately the size of a quarter of
Earth's moon he then contacts the
president who just wakes up next to her
daughter David a genius now working for
a television cable company is playing
chess with his Dad he still wears his
wedding ring even though he has been
divorced for years he then goes to the
office to find all News Channel signals
have been inexplicably scrambled David
with his knowledge deduces that the
signal scrambling is not his fault and
figures out a way to fix it meanwhile at
Imperial Valley California Russ a drunk
pilot Waters the wrong field angry
landowners are confronting his children
Miguel Lisa and Troy even though they
despise their own dad at the White House
Connie the director of communications is
busy keeping up with the press the
president and other important figures
are discussing their stance lately the
thing has orbited the Earth and released
around three dozen smaller spacecraft to
make things worse it is the weekend and
almost the 4th of July so many Military
Officers are on leave thus
counter-attacks are not yet ready alien
attacks have been reported in Iraq the
Persian Gulf and California many
civilians and Military Officers die
because of unexplained phenomena the
president initiates emergency protocol
but refuses to evacuate himself he tells
Connie to create an emergency broadcast
telling people not to panic meanwhile
Russ is drinking at a local bar when
people come to mock him for his
extraterrestrial experience he claims to
be abducted by alien years ago and the
resulting trauma caused him to be a
drunk and eccentric person the alien
spacecraft are stationed above New York
Washington DC and California causing
earthquakes Captain Hiller a U.S marine
pilot is sleeping with Jasmine his
girlfriend when the earthquake happens
but thinks it has nothing to worry about
meanwhile David is too busy programming
the signal that he does not realize the
imminent threat his whole office
evacuates to an old bomb shelter
Hiller wakes up to see his neighbors
frantically packing up to leave the city
and finally realizes the threat David
sees the spacecraft and news then
deduces the signal as a synchronized
countdown for the aliens to position
themselves before they simultaneously
attack Earth he contacts his ex-wife
Connie who is accompanying the president
to give a speech at the White House he
tells her to get out of there but she
hangs up Hiller is called to report to
the El Toro base canceling his leave and
disappointing Jasmine the president
calls his wife and tells her that he
does not want her in any of the major
cities David meets his dad and asks him
to drive to Washington he hopes to help
Connie in the government's defense
against the aliens his dad discourages
him by telling the government knows what
they are doing
Russ children want to leave town without
him Hiller reports back to El Toro and
Jimmy his wingman discovers his planned
wedding ring meanwhile Jasmine still
works as a stripper but the situation on
the news is getting worse so she decides
to leave town David and his dad Julius
arrive at the White House he uses
Connie's phone signal to triangulate her
exact position Connie takes the
president to meet David despite their
past conflict David tells him that the
aliens are using Earth satellite systems
to create a countdown as they speak the
Pentagon launches a retro helicopter
with a Visual Communications device to
establish interaction with the aliens
after the president observes the
helicopter being shot down and learns
about the countdown from David he
commences Nationwide evacuation the
first lady is in Los Angeles while a few
weird people beg at the rooftops to be
taken by these aliens the aliens
countdown stops while David and the
president are on Air Force One Los
Angeles New York and Washington are
attacked simultaneously Jasmine survives
by Sheltering herself with Dylan and
Boomer their dog at a tunnel inspection
Alcove unfortunately the first lady's
helicopter never makes it to the
assembly point the president Mourns the
death of his people especially because
his wife vice president and Chiefs did
not survive Captain Hiller and a squad
prepared a counter-attack they
discovered that the alien spacecraft and
its Fighters have a force field that
protects them from the military's
missiles the military sustains heavy
losses including Jimmy but Hiller
survives the attack and defeats one of
the aliens after making it Maneuvers and
crashes into a canyon meanwhile Jasmine
retrieves a truck from the city ruins
the defense secretary wants to launch a
nuclear attack but the president resists
thinking it will only cause more
unnecessary deaths people aboard Air
Force One then have different opinions
on how to solve the crisis Julius
releases his anger to the government
telling them that they should be
responsible for the area 51 tragedy in
the 1950s the president calms him by
saying that there is no alien conspiracy
at Area 51 but the defense secretary
defies the statement and brings the
plane there
Jasmine helps wounded survivors get out
of the city to El Toro Hiller drags the
aliens corpse through the desert while
he bumps into Caravans of fleeing
citizens he asks them to be delivered to
a nearby Air Base that is not on the map
which is Area 51 where the president's
team is also heading they learn from Dr
Oken the head of the research facility
that a crash in the 1950s resulted in
three dead aliens and a retrieved
spaceship they have learned many things
about the species but could not figure
out its advanced technology David helps
them by figuring out the aliens
communication signal while they suddenly
receive news that an injured species has
been brought to the facility by Hiller
Hiller also arrives with groups of
survivors he learns that El Toro is
destroyed thinking Jasmine did not
survive Jasmine also arrives at El
Toro's ruins and thinks he did not
survive she and the survivors one of
them turns out to be the first lady make
camp for the night
Dr okan dissects the injured alien but
it comes alive and attacks him and his
team the president watches through a
glass where the alien establishes a
telepathic connection with him before it
is killed by the Secret Service the
president learns that it wants to
annihilate all life on Earth thus he
authorizes nuclear attacks the first
Target is Houston Texas meanwhile Hiller
steals a helicopter to find Jasmine in
El Toro he is able to evacuate Jasmine
and other survivors bringing them to
area 51. the nuclear attack turns out to
be unsuccessful since a force field
still protects the alien ship the
president aborts all nuclear attacks
which is disapproved by his defense
secretary however he is immediately
fired
the president regroups with his badly
injured wife at area 51. doctors tell
him she has not much hope to survive
adding to his sadness meanwhile
frustrated David gets drunk and destroys
things at the lab Julius comes to him
telling him to look after his own health
or he would catch a virus the phrase
inspires David as he is suddenly eager
to demonstrate something he shows that
he can upload a computer virus through
the aliens communication signal that
will destroy their force fields and
enable a massive counter-attack to do
that he must log on to the mothership's
communication Network so the virus will
be transmitted to the smaller ships
people are being hesitant about the plan
but Hiller volunteers to Pilot the 1950s
alien ship that will bring him and David
to the Mothership both Jasmine and
Connie are anxious about the decision
Hiller marries Jasmine before he leaves
for the mission with David and Connie as
the witnesses Connie realizes David
never takes his wedding ring and
reconciles with him
meanwhile General gray of the U.S army
organizes a worldwide counter-attack
effort the Army spreads the news using
Morse code and surviving armies all over
the world are eager to join the
president an Air Force pilot himself
volunteers to lead a squad as Pilots or
scarce everyone capable of flying planes
is being summoned to Area 51 including
Russ he is proud to serve the nation and
avenge what those aliens did to him
years ago Hiller and David leave the
base after adapting themselves to the
alien spaceship situation they shortly
arrive at the mothership it then takes
control of their ship so they glide
through the mothership on autopilot they
witness millions of aliens preparing for
an invasion before the ship is finally
docked David successfully uploads the
virus after that General gray tells the
president to launch a strike the first
missile does not come through but the
second is a direct hit so the squad
becomes hopeful to attack more and fight
off the alien Fighters the spacecraft
they are attacking is about to fire its
primary weapon but they are almost out
of missiles suddenly Russ claims that he
still has one missile left so the
president and his team clear away for
him to reach the main weapon however
Russ missile stuck and thinking about
his children he sacrifices himself by
crashing his plane into the weapon just
before it fires the spacecraft is
completely destroyed luckily for the
president he can get away safely
after uploading the virus Hiller and
David should release a nuclear missile
and get out of the alien Mothership but
they are stuck at the parking dock the
aliens become suspicious of their ship
so they surround it thinking they have
lost they lit their Victory cigars while
activating the nuclear missile after it
is ejected their shipstock suddenly
Breaks Loose they now have 30 seconds to
get out of the ship just before the
nuclear explodes Hiller's skills enable
them to escape just before the
mothership becomes ruins meanwhile on
the ground the president's Squad is back
at Area 51 and receives a joyful welcome
from all citizens however Jasmine and
Connie almost lose hope when they learn
that Hiller and David's ship have lost
contact suddenly a signal emerges in the
middle of a desert they quickly head
there to find David and Hillary
surviving the mission they Embrace each
other's families and celebrate
Independence Day
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching